foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the economist
Carol Malone and the editor of The
Courier in Dundee David Clegg they'll be
with us from now right up until just
before midnight so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
well the Merit leads where that's Rod
Stewart's a stinging attack on the
government over the crisis in the NHS
the telegraph also covers that story on
their front page but leads on the
controversial transgender law in
Scotland
the eye leads with the conservative
party chairman Nadeem zahawi giving hmrc
permission to speak to the investigation
into his handling of his tax affairs
the guardian also covers the Harvey's
tax Affairs while leading on anger over
the government's u-turn on implementing
Windrush inquiry recommendations
the mail previews the chancellor Jeremy
Hunt's plan for economic growth
well those plans are also covered by The
Daily Express with the plea for Jeremy
Hunt to talk up Britain's forecasts
the Metro reports on an alarming rise in
the number of young children being
sexually abused by online predators
the financial times has word of a blunt
pep talk given to staff at Rolls-Royce
by their incoming chief executive
while the sun leads on Freddie flintoff
putting his TV career on hold after his
car crash while filming an episode of
Top Gear
David's paper The Courier speaks to 12
year old Kaylin Donald who was attacked
on a bus on the day her grandfather died
and uses an editorial to demand School
leaders and politicians take action on
bullying
and the star wonders whether we could
one day see a robot uprising
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Carol
Malone and David Clegg welcome to both
of you let's start with the I there
front page and the latest on Nadeem
zahawi's tax Affairs Carol take us into
this
yeah and and the dream zahari has
finally given permission to age MRC to
make his tax Affairs public I mean this
is a huge blow to him I think he thought
at one point this might all go away seem
to quiet down earlier in the week but
it's just not going away and it was it
was very uncomfortable today watching
the boss of hmrc Jim Harrah and being
questioned by the committee I mean they
were asking so Harvey's name was never
mentioned but they were asking questions
that clearly pertained to him and they
were saying you know would hmrc publicly
make public a public person's tax
Affairs and Jim Harris said no that they
they wouldn't do that and he also talked
about how carelessness as a concept in
law
um
and he also talked about penalties for
um people who didn't pay the tax they
should have paid but what he's saying is
people who make instant mistakes
um don't pay penalties now that
completely blows the Harvey's arguments
and and defense out of the water and
today he's in uh Checkers with the rest
of the cabinet
um it's called an away day but everyone
is calling it a hideaway day because at
least it's he doesn't have to answer
questions today this is going to get
very embarrassing for him now Tories are
now saying he should go they're urging
him to go so that this doesn't drag on
and doesn't do any more damage to the
Tory party which it's hard to see and
the Tories could be any more damaged
currently but anyway they're urging them
to go um he should go now he really
should you can't have the bloke in
charge of the country's tax Affairs not
paying the correct amount of tax I mean
in his case ignorance is simply not an
excuse carelessness is not an excuse him
of all people should have made sure he
paid the amount of time he should have
done David should should he go
yes I think he should go I agree with
pretty much everything Carol said there
I think it just
amplifies this feeling that uh is held
so widely now that it's one rule for
them and one rule for the rest of us
that I I think is attitude throughout
this actually has been incredible we
knew when this story was first being
investigated or as tax Affairs I should
say was first being investigated by
journalists and tax researchers he was
making legal threats he was dying
playing it I believe he even told uh
this channel uh back over the summer
that was it was all a smear no well
noise had the Settler's Bill and he's uh
it's incredible almost that he's he's
deemed to allow the investigator access
to his tax records which seems like the
very least you could expect in these
circumstances there was a lovely irony
today actually because there was a Hugo
of pool the pulster which of course uh
he founded and some of these complicated
Financial Arrangements seemed to date
back to well they pulled and well should
resign and two-thirds of the public
think you should resign as well so it's
not just me and Carol it's the vast
majority of the public according to the
pollster he set up so yes he should go
yeah that is an interesting twister and
the Prime Minister hasn't quite given
him his full support has he Carol
until yeah
and that's the time that people who
messed up should get worried when when
the Prime Minister goes quiet and isn't
backing you yeah I mean where she combat
him you know the tour is it's just like
it's one disaster after another at the
moment and I mean it's just you know
they are simply heading for Wipeout at
the next election this is you know he
can't support a man who hasn't paid the
correct amount of tax I mean this wasn't
you know there's some he has had to pay
it's a seven figure something was all to
do with the same of yougov um I think it
was something like 28 million he he got
for his um share of the shares
um and you can't you
getting a seven figure so I'm wrong the
rest of us might make little mistakes on
a few gritty and a few good there but
what you're talking seven Figures it's
just it's just ludicrous let's have a
look at the mirror oh sorry you wanted
to say something to David
I I was just going to say I think it's
particularly damaging for Rishi sunak
because the whole point of his
Premiership was going to be to get away
from the Boris Johnson era to say that
things had changed that this wouldn't be
tolerated and whatever happens now it
looks really slow to have responded and
also so strangely and curious to not
have looked into this earlier after
being on top of this well whenever he
appointed to high to his cabinet so I
think it's it you can't imagine a worse
on goal for what Rishi sunak needs to
achieve to try and turn around the
fortunes of the conservative party let's
move to the mirror Carol and uh this
headline quite clever uh Rod We are
failing this is a Rod Stewart talking
about the state of the NHS uh calling in
actually to to Sky news to share his
views I use an amazing skill for you
guys today I mean no one could quite
believe it I hear
um who didn't know whether it was true
or not yeah he rang in and he just said
that he has now changed his political
affiliations he's been a tory for a very
long time and he says he's not what he's
now saying is give labor a go because
the Tories have messed it off I mean
I'll take I'll talk about that in a
minute it's not I don't know if that's
strictly true but anyway he rang and he
just said he's offered to pay he's let's
we're talking about you guys were
talking about one particular Clinic
where people couldn't get scams and they
were a matter of life or death and and
Rod has just said I'll pay for some of
these Scouts I'll pay for 10 I'll pay
for 20. but that isn't really the point
the point is that we can't have a
National Health Service where people are
dying simply because they can't get
scams I mean it's it's outrageous you
know this this all now points to what
has to happen within the NHS he's right
this is what he said today is gonna
assign a an even brighter light on on a
system that is failing you know it's we
keep on pumping money into it but it
just needs more than that you know it
just needs root and Branch reform
sergeant jabard said a few weeks ago the
ex held secretary he said you know there
had to be a hard-headed Converse station
to ensure the survival of the NHS and
that is that is absolutely true you know
and I think part of the problem in
recent years has been that the NHS has
become the sacred cow we're all grateful
to the nurses and the doctors for what
they've done for us individuals for our
families for the people we love
um but the bottom line is the
organization doesn't work you know it's
an it's the biggest employer of people
in Europe it's one of the most highly
funded organizations in Europe and yet
it doesn't work it's getting record
amounts of money until at the moment and
it's just being a lot of it is being
wasted the doctors and nurses are doing
their job they're working like hell on
the front line but you know the people
who are managing the organization just
aren't doing it right and there has to
be root and Branch before you know well
there's got to be some radical and
controversial moves made for the NHS to
survive I'm not sure labor other people
to do that
um but you know we can talk about that
later uh so Rod does uh believe that
David doesn't hear and he's saying that
he's actually never seen it so bad and
in all the years that he's lived in this
country
yes I think regardless of Weller
Carroll's analysis about it being not a
party political point one of the one of
the points I should make as I'm here in
Scotland is that the NHS in Scotland is
facing all the same challenges as is the
NHS in Wales and then Scotland is run by
the SMP and then Wales it's run uh by a
labor-led government so it that feels it
maybe taking the party political element
out of this might be useful in saying
that with uh the the road Steward issue
I I think the problem for the
conservatives is that you know you can
be cynical about well they're a
celebrity saying something is going to
influence minds but I think the the more
important issue is that I think he
actually represents what is quite a
large stream of opinion uh traditional
conservative voters as he described
himself who have that kind of one nation
Tory Heritage that they're appalled by
what's happening with the NHS and they
are going to be pinning it on the
conservative government so it feels to
me like another issue that caused real
problems for the conservatives although
I think there is an argument about well
or any political party can really take
the blame for it or well you have to
look at the wider structural issues and
have an honest conversation about how we
want to deliver Health Care yeah Elsa
Rod was saying that he definitely backs
the the nurses all the way and need the
action that they're taking but we read
in the Metro that city workers pay has
risen more than three times faster than
the wages of nurses paramedics and
midwives this is since 2008 Carol
yeah I mean yeah I mean it is
astonishing in the one sense but in the
other sense it's not astonishing because
we know that that nurses pay has fallen
behind in real terms um I haven't got
the PC I haven't
says that that the nurses have lost 42
Grand in real earnings since 2008 which
is an astonishing amount of money it's
just you know it's it's shocking you
know I I don't agree with stripes I
really don't agree with people who are
in the business of saving lives going on
strikes but of all the people who are
currently striking at the moment the
nurses are the ones that I believe have
in in real terms have lost the most
money over the past few years you know
paramedics there's an argument that
there's not an argument there's a report
says they haven't lost money in real
terms over the past 10 years but nurses
have it's five or six percent in the in
the past decade alone so you know yeah
nurses should have you know if we're
going to say to the people in the
emergency services don't go on strike we
have to give them decent pay Rises they
have to be you know not stupid pay rise
not 10 15 but decent ones ones that
don't insult them so yeah I mean it is
it is shocking but totally unexpected
that the people in the city's wages are
rising faster well actually the TUC
analysis is saying that uh paramedics
and midwives have actually lost 56 000
even more than nurses in real terms
David the TU TUC can say that but
there's a report from the Department of
Health which says not that David I I
will not adjudicate on that right as I
don't have the the details at my
fingertips but but what I will say is
that this has uh clearly been a briefing
from the union and it's it's quite
astute because the the the numbers uh
make it clear that nurses in particular
uh and these health workers who are
um worried so worried about their pay
and fighting so hard to get a better
settlement dating it back to 2008 and
comparing it to the finance industry
clearly uh is very politically clever
because we all remember what happened in
2000 denier to knew how to clean up the
aftermath so to see wages Rising more in
that sector I think I think will
resonate with people uh and there's a
bit of astute politicking from whosoever
is given the briefing to the Metro
just time Carol to take us into the
mailer and their story concerning uh
what Jeremy Hunt will be saying today in
uh well actually sorry tomorrow in an
address
um that really should talk up the
economy and rather than being negative
and that's that's the call from
conservatives
because I haven't seen it I I I've seen
a bit of this I can David go ahead
briefing it's a it's a briefing to the
meal and it's also carried in the
express about what the chancellor Jeremy
Hunt is going to say in his speech
tomorrow this is clearly high stakes
trying to turn around they're appalling
uh pulls at the minute uh the general
public contempt and all the scandals
that we've just been outlining and it
seems to be focusing on two things which
is building on what that's calling
brexit advantages which were let's face
it still to see any of really and but
also warning against talking Britain
down this idea of declinism so it's
trying to put an optimistic spin uh on
where the economy is sitting but saying
very much that this has to be done by
tackling low productivity so I think
those are probably some themes that
we'll see the conservative government
developing over the months ahead
Jessica said he's got it you can he can
say all that but he's got to set out a
real plan for growth in the next 12
months because that's what we need now
there's no you know we have to have
growth in this country businesses are
going to fail you know we have you know
we we've found out the other week that
half of the population in this country
are receiving more in bet in from
welfare than they actually pay in tax so
so you know we're in the best that way
yeah you know he needs to put he needs
to pause business rates and unfreeze
allowances and let people start making
some money well what is he's hoping to
do is make the case for optimism and uh
he'll claim the EU red tape has held
back investment in productivity but
future growth can be built on the
freedoms which brexit provides welcome
back you're watching the Press preview
is still with me Carol Malone and David
Clegg we're going to take a look at
David's paper The Courier and this story
about uh bullying a campaign that The
Courier is waging against it David take
us into this story
yes the LA the last week has really
involved reporting on some of the most
distressing stories I can remember in my
career yeah it started with a school in
Fife called weight academy and it was a
video that was circulating of a really
horrendous assault on a school girl it
happened in a classroom if it had
happened on a street amongst adults
someone would have ended up in yield and
the response to our original story uh
was it really just opened the Pandora's
Box because we've subsequently been
inundated with uh concerned parents at
their wit's end because their children
are being bullied in school and nobody
seems to be doing anything about it a
real a real fear of just sending their
kids to school people who are not
homeschooling their children because
they don't trust schools to protect them
and they're just there just seems to be
a real lack of agency for teachers to be
able to deal with it and actually got to
the stage that was raised at the
Scottish Parliament and Nicolas
sturgeons looking into the issue in
tomorrow's paper we've we've spoken to a
very brave uh 12 year old Killen Donald
who was uh beaten up on a bus the day
after her grandfather died uh just
trying to get home from school and that
as all these incidents seemed to be was
of course filmed uh because something
that's playing in my view a real uh is a
real factor in the escalation and how
this is a much bigger problem bullying
has always been something that's existed
in schools but I fear it's a much more
acute problem now than it's ever been
because it's not just it just doesn't
happen once it's captured on video and
then it's circulated on social media we
find 70 social media accounts uh solely
dedicated to videos or pictures or
content about bullying of of children
being bullied uh on on social media
platforms like Instagram and Tech talk
and that was just for our small area of
Scotland and Tay side and Fife now
there's no reason to believe that our
areas worse affected than anywhere else
it's just that's where we happen to be
looking so I I really want to pay
tribute uh to Kailyn for uh speaking
publicly she wanted to share her story
to try and get something to get
something done about this we have a
front page editorial tomorrow
urging uh policy makers and education
bosses in Scotland to step up to the
plate here it will also involve social
media companies doing something about us
but I really believe this is a this is
an issue that needs to be tackled and
tackled quickly